what was the last time he went back home
to where you grew up and what was your
epiphany okay what would went through
your mind having all life experience
under need your belt what hit you I'm
sure that by the powerful emotion titian
hood well last time i've been to last
time I went to Honduras I was 16 years
old I was 16 years old and the things
changed a lot of things change over
there when I went over there but still
same people as they stood still doing
the same old thing again human
trafficking that's still happening over
there over and over again and turn your
TV right now you can hear every day that
somebody some kids being kidnapped so
that still happening a lot of endurance
and but nothing has changed when I went
over it was just the same old same old
place that I grew up and as a kid and he
hasn't changed that much she's the same
same place hasn't changed it's still the
same thing happening around that area
but people being taking away kidnapped
and stuff so is anything going back to
New York I was in New York last month a
lot of the kids that I grew up with
getting released when I used to living
in your recent shell in front of the
stairs ain't gone from the stairs and
watch the girls walk by and stuff like
that but like boy 19 years old so after
a while you know I wanted to get out of
that by going back to New York last
month and all the people that I grew up
with they still doing the same then I'm
like wow you guys still doing that that
same thing we did back in the day that I
will lose like 10 years old you like 30
file right now so it hasn't changed so
but my view in life but just going back
to the Milwaukee I'm doing the right
thing and we keep going forward these
guys are still doing the same thing and
um it's just a it's just weird because
it kind of not kind of put me above
everybody else because in on
I don't put myself that high you know
but up your side it was just a weird
vibe when I went back on i can't believe
these people are still doing that's cuz
you were different yeah yeah yeah
changing the way a little bit you know
i'm about yeah that's my experience
going back home yeah I think I i went to
i was back in New York last year and I
Love New York oh it's get exciting when
I go back and you know that that New
York is still my city no matter where I
go that's always going to be home and
you know then it definitely changed the
city moves so fast it's like you could
be going like three weeks a year like
what that's not the new club anymore
it's like things have changed you know
but uh I'd say yeah I definitely when I
go back home I could feel the journey
that I've travelled you know when I when
I go back because then I you know I
think back of oh when I was on this
corner the last time I was doing this
and Wow take it back to denton I didn't
even know I be I never thought I was
going to be a director ever so you know
I oh I constantly have epiphanies
because this was not anything that i was
planning as a child or anything like
that so it I constantly you know look
back and be like wow I ended up here you
know and it is cool i feel you know
satisfied and rewarded and you know hope
i can somehow keep it going to use those
memories
absolute laws absolutely I look at every
setback every every time I thought I
couldn't do something but then you know
somehow you know put my head down and
just up before you know it I did it
already and now I've been doing it for
quite a while now and I can do this
thing I mean I've been through
epiphanies with a lot of those with
engineering and you know I've done like
you know tours and music tours as an
engineer and you know you get put in a
lot of different environments you know
and it's basically in a lot of sink or
swim environments to and now and doing
that phone over the time in years and
years and years I kind of get accustomed
to you know not necessarily being in it
because you never get comfortable but
you get comfortable dealing with the
stress of things and anxiety of things
and I had one of the actors when we were
shooting a trailer for for amber and it
was it was the second day and I was
walking past me to say hey hey so you
nervous yet and I was just like if
you're not nervous you're not doing
anything and I was just like but my
nervous level is about here and i'll
keep it right about here and I was just
like but I like that I'm excited when
I'm nervous because that means things
are at stake life is being lived so I
mean I love those moments so you know I
never shy away from outlook for good
opportunities and stuff I've never done
before or not and if I want to do it a
minute all away I dive in and you know
to me those are the best times
you